well it certainly was a lick of snap
judgment but I felt that there has
always been a lot of industry around me
and a lot of questions and it took me a
while you know I had to watch the casket
together I had to watch then we do the
carpet at the VMAs and when I saw them
all together it felt a lot more real I
was approached for this or like you know
three four months and I was really like
at first I just took it as a joke and I
was like no why would I ever do that and
then you know after a lot of
deliberation on it
I think the hills is one of the kindest
of the TV shows and it really is of the
reality realm and it's not your average
sort of like reality situation and
they're married they have kids they have
businesses and life is different you can
never tell where a season is gonna go I
found out now from reality TV but it is
very interesting that everybody's older
and wiser so you would hope and then you
watch the show and you'll get to see
where everybody's up what was the
hardest part about putting yourself out
there oh all of it because I mean it's
like coming into a new group of friends
as well and like or more just like the
fact that they kind of operate in their
own way and they have a lot of things
that have not been reconciled and sorted
out over the last ten years so sometimes
it felt like I was just playing catch-up
a lot of the time and I'm really not one
for like snap decisions and judgments
and I don't tend to like I tried to be
the voice of reason so it would be very
interesting to try and it's kind of like
toe the line with everything that was
going on but also like vocalize the way
I felt about things when pushed so yeah
it's it's a lot of things where did they
embrace you know as a cast member and
some more than others but you know yes
they did certainly but again they had a
lot of their own things to work out so I
think the least of their worries was
really who was new to the group because
they do know me
over the years so even if everybody's
not hanging out every single day like
know each other are you a fan of the
original series at all yeah I mean I
didn't watch it because I was busy doing
the OSI and I was busy working and
traveling but I was very aware of what
they got up to and yeah I just again
mutual friends different events and
stuff like that
so yeah in some strange way is it a
full-circle moment for you sort of
starting on the OSI and then yes it's
wild because you know they OC started
all of these reality shows because it
was so wildly popular and yeah it's
really it's a fun it's a fun full circle
expect a new show a lot I think you know
there's love there's arguments there's
family there's like life kids all sorts
of things love for you you'll have to
see